the number of people living with
dementia in the uk is forecast to rise
by 75 percent by 2050 to almost 1.6
million the global burden of disease
study which is published in the lancet
says cases worldwide will triple unless
key risk factors are addressed now these
risk factors include smoking obesity
high blood sugar and low education i'm
joined now by the head of research at
the alzheimer's society richard oakley
very good to see you this evening
really worrying these statistics because
of course they mean uh
much more heartache for so many people
who are affected by it
yeah that's absolutely right i mean
these figures confirm i think what we've
expected and kind of knew but haven't
had the data really to show
that the number of people
affected by dementia is growing um and
the this paper highlights the biggest
risk factors are growing population and
age
and unless
we look at some of the modifiable risk
factors um like you mentioned there with
obesity and high high blood sugar unless
we take action this is what will happen
but i think that the underlying message
is an empowering one it's it's a
positive one this is what is forecast to
happen but we have done so much research
the outside society has been leading on
this and we know there are things that
everyone can do to reduce their risk and
i think it shows what happens if we
don't do that but we absolutely can and
you outlined uh some of the things that
that are causing this increase but
aren't we doing better aren't we all
eating more healthily aren't we smoking
less
yeah we are and i think that this data
obviously looks at many countries it's a
global reflection um and it does look at
smoke and obesity and i think smoking is
going down but obesity i think we can
i'm not so sure about but also there's
high blood sugar and education levels
but we know there are actually about 12
modifiable risk factors in this paper
obviously i looked at some of those and
i think really one of the messages that
has got through to the public is about
what's good for your heart and we know
smoking and taking regular exercise and
drinking moderation are good but they
are good for your brain too and we
really need that message to get through
to to individuals to empower them to
make a difference but also to to policy
makers um so that we can create an
environment where people are able to
live those healthier lives and
understand and know what is what is good
for them yeah it's quite a hard message
to get across isn't it because uh we all
know that obesity uh uh can affect you
physically in many many different ways
but we don't necessarily associate
obesity with our with our minds with our
brains
no that's absolutely right i mean we do
link obesity to many different diseases
but not to our brain the most important
organ in our body but it's absolutely
correct and i think that studies like
this are so important for highlighting
the fact that there are things we can do
and the authors call for it's like more
aggressive action in prevention and we
do know we have seen reduction in
prevalence rates in the uk where people
have been taking positive action but we
need to see more but i think over the
last number of years we've done so much
research we understand more about
dementia than we ever have and research
will be dementia prevention's a vital
part of that um and the outside society
we're very dependent on the public's
generosity and donations and we need to
make sure kobe doesn't stall the
progress we've been made and we're also
calling on the government to kind of
realize it's promised to double spending
in dementia research the dementia
moonshot so-called because we are at a
pivotal point this data shows what could
happen unless we take action so we need
to make sure everyone realizes that and
knows they can all make an individual
difference to their risk of dementia how
we're doing in finding a cure for
dementia
so there hasn't been a new treatment in
in the uk for 20 years now which is a
long time but we do have over 120
clinical trials going on globally and
it's probably never been as good as it
has been there are challenges this is a
very difficult disease dementia's an
umbrella term for at least 130 different
diseases that of course the symptoms
that we describe as dementia but we've
never been more positive and i think we
are not far away we can see and like the
end of the tunnel where we are
developing really exciting treatments
that we hope are going to be available
shortly we just can't let um the
pandemic and the reductions spending
either through charities like the
outside society our government store the
momentum because we really are at the
cusp of developing those early
treatments which will slow down the
progression of the disease
and of course you've got a personal
experience of dementia i know you've
talked about it publicly before but you
know just how key
uh it is to try and make those
changes yeah absolutely i mean i think
we all want to see uh that treatment i
think research will be dementia it has
beaten many other diseases that will be
dementia we need time and money
investment to to develop those
treatments but there are many other
aspects are the prevention aspect
mentioned in this paper where we can
empower people to
to live maybe slightly healthier lives
smoke less drink let's take a bit more
exercise that can affect their
individual risk
we also know there's a lot we need to do
in the the social care space and the
care and the quality of life that we
provide people who have been affected by
dementia and the support we give to the
family who often take up a lot of the
caring responsibility so there's a lot
we can do right now to improve the
quality of people's lives there's a lot
we can do to help prevent more cases and
of course we have the outside society
and others are working really hard on
those treatments yeah and and finally
you've touched on this already but we
know people do give very generously to
charities such as yours but uh do you
feel the government's doing enough when
it comes to that research
well the government has played a big
role in the last decade the dementia
research institute is a fantastic
institute based in uk really bringing
some of the best minds into dementia
into the united kingdom to do this
research which is fantastic but they did
make a commitment a promise to doubling
dementia research which is fantastic and
could make the uk really a global super
interventional research and we're still
waiting for that to be realized so of
course i absolutely call for for that to
be released to the environment lately
yeah global superpower in research would
be great wouldn't it alright dr richard
oakley thank you very much indeed for
your time